while its development seems to be
undergoing some retooling all signs
point to capcom working on a remake of
resin evil 4 for the playstation 5 and
xbox whatever
after the wild critical and financial
success of the previous two remakes
and a lot of people like myself are very
on the fence about that
well a lot of others welcome it with
open arms because they think it'll
breathe new life into a tired
outdated ancient dinosaur of a game from
thousands of generations ago that is
obviously unplayable by today's
rigid standards of gaming now obviously
from the sound of my high pitched
michael j
fox voice i'm still pretty young and in
my time on youtube i've had my opinions
dismissed quite a few times due to my
age
like all the people telling me i'm wrong
for disliking mortal kombat 4 because
you just had to be there youngin when my
opinion of it was that it didn't have as
much charm or imagination as the games
that were even older
but i'm turning 23 soon and i feel it's
time that i've exercised my right to say
everyone saying resident evil 4 has aged
poorly
is a dumb ass zoomer that needs to sit
down because the adults are talking
hearing the constant bemoaning screech
of takes from people who grew up spoiled
by playing resident evil 2 remake which
is to say they're still children
about how mild tank controls are too
hard to get used to is like the same
nails on a chalkboard as someone saying
i can't watch this movie it's in black
and white
well junior that's what we had to work
with at the time it's one thing to talk
about how a piece of media has aged but
you also need to keep in mind the time
period it was released in for the
context of that discussion
how was it when it was created what did
it have to offer in the grand scheme of
things
yes halloween is incredibly generic and
predictable movie by today's standards
but that's because it was so
groundbreaking and new at the time that
we've seen
40 years of movies ripping it off
because of its originality and skillful
execution
at the time and in resident evil 4's
case this game is a masterpiece that
completely redefined the horror genre in
video games
and basically invented a new style of
gameplay that has persisted well into
2021 and
beyond no thanks bro if you're a fan of
the new remake games
evil then dead space and hell even the
last of us to some extent they're all
built on the blueprint of resident evil
4.
that's not to say it's a perfect game or
anything but it's pretty damn close
and with rumors circulating now more
than ever about the game getting a shiny
new update in the same vein as re2 and 3
i can't help but think it doesn't need a
remake
and i'm not just defending it because of
nostalgia i didn't sit down and play
this game myself all the way until
[ __ ] 2020.
i watched my dad play it when it came
out as a kid but if we're being honest
we played resident evil 2 way more
because it was scarier
and yeah that game could totally use a
remake this was great but there's a
world of difference between
this and this not nearly as much
difference between this
and this let's get the basics out of the
way does it desperately need a visual
upgrade
not really graphically this game was
ahead of its time these
models were incredibly detailed compared
to most stuff on ps2
and were very expressive and believably
animated sure the textures can be sort
of muddy at times in the environment we
hadn't quite figured out harry yet in
video games
and on the new reports you can see some
lower poly models and crowd shots
but i'd say this and silent hill 3 were
some of the best looking games i could
recall from that era
who cares anyway graphic schmaffix
making such a gigantic deal out of that
is why the medium is so confused about
what it wants to be right now with hyper
realism and immersion being put ahead of
being fun to play for more than an hour
what matters is the gameplay and i could
run around suplexing mutant villagers
and roundhouse kicking giant insects all
day
and again i could somewhat understand
the criticism that the controls are sort
of clunky and tank like by today's
standards
you know because you gotta turn side to
side
and move forward and backward but you
know what the camera stays behind you at
all times it's
like playing ps1 spiderman shut the hell
up yeah it sucks that you can't walk and
shoot at the same time
your movement is a little limited in the
heat of the moment it can be difficult
to orient yourself the right way while
being crowded by enemies
having to use the other trigger to
select a knife can sometimes be
confusing and a pain in the ass
these are all things that are true as we
all know this gameplay style was
introduced by re4
and then perfected in the immaculate
masterpiece bestowed upon us by the gods
known as dead space
specifically dead space 2's gameplay is
buttery smooth perfection that will
stand the test of time forever
with no need for an update resident evil
4 can't quite make that same claim
however and call me old-fashioned but
i'm not of the mindset that because it
has flaws we should just throw the whole
thing out and dump millions of dollars
and thousands of man-hours into starting
from scratch
the mild stiffness and the gameplay goes
away once you've played it for
i don't know like 20 minutes and there's
still a lot of fun to be had with the
shooting mechanics and the combat in
spite of it
it's just something you gotta get used
to even that doesn't take nearly as long
as the style of the older games
static fixed camera angles obtuse puzzle
design
frustrating tank controls stilted
dialogue and voice acting
and ancient low poly visuals are
perfectly valid reasons to want a modern
update for these games
these are not very accessible to
newcomers sitting down and learning how
to play
these myself when i was in high school
was like trying to learn chess from your
grandpa
sometimes you just want to play hungry
hungry hippos but like
in this metaphor re4 is that because
it's
incredibly accessible the solution to 90
of this game's puzzles are just
[ __ ] shoot it with your gun idiot and
there's not really any exploration or
backtracking
it's all a really linear jaunt from
point a to b
and while it occasionally loops back in
on itself with a familiar location
that's a far cry from good old resident
evil one
i've walked by this annoying ticking
clock 14 times in the last hour
and if i have to backtrack down this
same hallway
one more time i'm going to eat my hat
i've always wanted a resident evil game
where you have the option to mark your
footsteps on the floor and they stay the
entire playthrough
so you can see any given room's floor
entirely covered by the end
now you could be of the mind that the
remake could improve the story i'm well
aware that people are turned off by re4
because
well it's dumb as all hell but in a fun
way
visit evil 4 story is that your
returning character leon kennedy who is
now a secret agent for the us government
that's been trained to be a one-man army
going to a small european village to
track down the president's daughter who
was mysteriously kidnapped by a radical
cult
of terrorists that mind control people
with mutated strains of the viruses that
made everyone zombies in the previous
games
i once read a youtube comment many years
ago where someone described resident
evil 4's plot
or lack thereof as can only be
summarized with the image of a zombie
mutant priest's head exploding
reflected in a pair of aviator
sunglasses
this game doesn't take itself very
seriously if you couldn't tell from
leon's constant one-liners wrestling
moves and complete indifference to the
death-defying stunts and
life-threatening situations he's
encountering i've sent my right hand
to dispose of you your right hand comes
off
die you work don't you think this is a
revolutionary way to
promulgate one's faith sounds more like
an alien invasion if you ask
me no thanks bro why don't you do us all
a favor and leave before the audience
gets pissed off
well i really don't give a damn rain or
shine
you're going down we've prepared a
special ritual for you
mind controlled mutant cultist firing a
flamethrower designed to look like a
giant stone dragon suspended with chains
from the ceiling in a room with floating
platforms above a pit of lava
whatever i don't give a [ __ ] i'm at work
right now [ __ ] you want a response talk
to weekend leon
the president's daughter ashley is
admittedly a pretty flat and
one-dimensional character in this game
but so is everyone because this game
wasn't striving to be that deep
i see this game as capcom's response to
the hollywood live-action resident evil
movies
almost like they saw the slow motion
ninja kicks and silly action sequences
and crazy laser hallways and said
wow that's really dumb and not at all
what the games were like
it's awesome we can do that too
and thus leon went from being an
underdog rookie police officer to
jet li jason bourne the game's entire
tone is a sarcastic send-up of american
action movie cliches
from the premise of rescuing the
president's daughter to the cheesy
foreign villain to the trophy locations
of an
evil castle and a well-guarded private
island with a secret base on it
the original resident evil already had
that hollywood action movie flavor to it
for fun
but it didn't quite go as far into the
territory of silliness as the fourth
game did
at least not intentionally this house
is dangerous there are terrible demons
ouch i can absolutely understand the
standpoint of not liking the campiness
of it the original trilogy was very
atmospheric and lonely and scary
those games tried to make you feel
pretty underpowered compared to the
enemy force
but in resident evil 4 leon's a badass
that mops the floor with
everyone with ease some of the horror is
stripped out when you're the most
capable and prepared person in the
universe and you feel like an
unstoppable death machine
it's like how the new doom games aren't
scary sure they have horror elements but
the most dangerous thing on the screen
at any given time is your own
fists but what exactly will the remake
do to fix that
just rewrite all the dialogues so leon's
more stoic and serious
take away your ability to do wrestling
moves and superhero landings
for realism i thought the big complaint
was that the gameplay was stiff and your
movement was limited you want them to
solve that by
taking away the combat mechanics and
movement you can't really disassociate
this game from the actiony stuff because
it's just so sturdily built around that
and taking away the silly villains and
dialogue would detract from the charm
and personality this game had over the
rest of the series that played things
more straight by this point
maybe you can give ashley more
personality or make leon seem less bored
by everything around him
thanks that should keep me company cause
boredom kills me
maybe even add some dialogue for them to
bond as characters during slow moments
and gameplay like some of these other
dad games
but there's not much you can really do
with salazar sadler
luis and krauser without just having to
make a different game
they're going to be pretty campy and
weird no matter what you do unless you
just
reinvent them entirely but you can't
have salazar
just a pale guy wearing a suit and tie
voiced by troy baker or something
whatever remake they put together it has
to be true to the spirit of the original
and that's inevitably going to have a
heavier action focus with a bizarre
sense of humor
at the end of the day if you don't like
resident evil 4
a top to bottom remake would not fix
that you still don't like resident evil
4
and it's totally valid to dislike it but
i'm just saying this won't plug all the
holes you're seeing man
i understand disliking the wacky humor
or the characters or the more
action-heavy approach that saps the
horror
and in terms of gameplay i can agree
that it could use some quality of life
upgrades like a faster way to switch
weapons or maybe some movement on par
with re3 remake because that game felt
pretty smooth
aiming and walking at the same time
would be nice maybe a better solution to
using your melee with your knife
but everything else is solid okay don't
you dare even talk about
okay this is the big one ashley
follows you around and she's fine
but people don't like her because they
don't know how to play the game good
this game for all intents and purposes
is an escort mission
you have to protect ashley from taking
damage and get her to safety
later games like bioshock infinite and
the last of us and probably 40 other
troy baker vehicles copied the formula
of a tough gruff action man protecting a
vulnerable young kid in gameplay but all
of them couldn't really solve the
problem of not making that character
annoying to take care of in gameplay
so they just didn't even try ellie and
elizabeth
and atreus and whoever the [ __ ] else are
typically
invincible in quite a few cases they're
also
invisible to enemies all they do is
stand there looking worried while you do
the combat and once in a while
throw you some ammo or health pickups
it's hard to make gamers feel empathy
for characters and games because
most of the time characters are either a
something you have to kill at all costs
or b a means to an end and nothing more
after a while every anthropomorphic
figure starts to look like an obstacle
and having to babysit an npc in the
middle of combat is just a pain in the
ass
eventually you just want to kill them
yourself because they keep taking damage
it builds resentment you can circumvent
this problem by making them impervious
to all damage and helpful by giving you
stuff or smashing bad guys you're not
paying attention to
a lot of people hate ashley graham
because she can be grabbed or killed
however in this instance i'll refer to
this formal diagnosis that has always
stuck with me
if you thought ashley was that difficult
to take care of you probably just suck
at the game
you walk into a combat area and there's
a convenient dumpster or closet sitting
there and you hit the button
that says [ __ ] dumpster and she hides
now she can't take damage enemies can't
even find her you don't even have to
stay near the dumpster
you can [ __ ] off and kill everything in
your wake then call her right back to
you
but let's say you don't have a hiding
spot she can't get in your line of fire
because she's always standing behind you
and even crouches out of your views so
you don't see her
you have to try to shoot her if enemies
are sneaking up behind you and hitting
her
then you weren't keeping track of your
spatial awareness and they would have
just hit you instead if she wasn't
standing there because she's like an
inch behind you she took an axe to the
face for you and essentially acts as a
buffer with extra health and you're
gonna be ungrateful
in my first playthrough of the game
ashley only died once because i
accidentally threw a grenade at her
that's on me she isn't the giant drag on
the fun factor of the game that people
exaggerate are out to be
and i know in the remake she'll
inevitably be indestructible just
because they don't want to hear
complaints from teenagers that skip
tutorials and then whine that the game
didn't teach them how to do things what
are you guys
me playing spider-man 3 hey i'm not
infallible i suck at things sometimes
too i'll own up to that
i have only one very important question
you gotta smoke at the moment the future
of this remake is uncertain because the
team working on it can't even really
decide
what to do with it half of them want to
do a reimagining like these other two
where it's more or less the same general
plot but all the details are scrambled
and the other half wants more of a
one-to-one remake where they just make
the same game again with a new engine
and voice acting
kinda like rez evil 1 remake which was
[ __ ] super cool
on the one hand doing something new with
it could possibly be fun
and justify the remake taking in a new
direction
might be cool but it would have to be
pretty different
and on the other hand i'm not opposed to
just playing the same game again but
smoother and better looking
my stance is not that there shouldn't be
a remake at all
but that this game just doesn't really
need one
those are not mutually exclusive i'll
definitely buy and play
whatever this turns out to be because i
love resident evil and i have since i
was 3 years old watching my dad
play re2 and print off a 100-page
walkthrough in case he got stuck because
the computer was in the other room
and phones didn't have internet yet
those memories stick with me
and i'll be a lifelong fan i just wanted
to offer a bit of perspective for the
admittedly vocal minority pushing for
this to be a thing
because of something they perceive as
being wrong or broken with the original
because it's
barely getting old and hey i'm happy for
anyone who gets to play the vr port
i can't afford the hardware to run that
on a youtuber salary because i've got
mouths to feed
but damn it if i won't feel excited for
anyone who can
hey just for fun let's go the cynical
angry guy rap
let's imagine the worst case scenario
based on these other remakes
for context i do like resident evil 3
remake but i feel some of its creative
choices were a little questionable
the game felt rushed i'd cut out the
only other boss character in the game
than nemesis it removed
a major set piece with the clock tower
that made the game feel extremely short
they essentially removed the middle act
of the story and now the pacing is so
slapdash that you're sprinting from the
start of the game straight to the ending
with little to no breathing room in the
middle and i felt a little cheated by
how nemesis had fewer boss forms and was
presented less like a looming threat
mr x in resident evil 2 was great
because he was always walking around and
following you
making progression nerve-wracking
because there were so many chances for
totally unscripted encounters with him
and that felt natural and unique
with nemesis he always felt kind of safe
because whenever he appeared it was
like a scripted thing that meant the
story was progressing
not a fight that could go anyway he
always just showed up whenever you made
too much progress and herded you
straight into the next part of the game
you weren't playing cat and mouse with
him he was just pushing you on rails
straight into a new level or new boss
fight
if they designed resident evil 4 from
scratch using resident evil 3 as a basis
for the decision making
i think resident evil 4 would look
something like this the village section
of the game is three hours shorter and
condensed into one large area instead of
several small ones spaced apart this
church right here would be turned into
this church
from later in the game for simplicity
the boss fight with the lake monster
would be a scripted cutscene
and you'd have to only throw one harpoon
to kill it if not
that being totally excised there will be
one boss
with the elhigante as a wink for fans
but the other three ones
won't show up at all ada and her
separate ways story will be turned into
a single level
where you can play as her while leon's
unconscious somewhere
[Music]
or just completely cut out ashley will
be wearing a tank top
and jeans swear like a sailor and be
completely impervious to enemy damage
leon will no longer be able to do
wrestling moves but will have that dodge
mechanic from re3
the castle will be heavily cut down into
a smaller area with less
silly and elaborate albeit fun and
memorable set pieces
salazar's statue will not be a giant
animatronic robot that chases you
because that's dumb
it'll just have explosive charges at the
base and will fall over
it'll also be way smaller and in an
earlier part of the castle it'll be like
in this room
the sewer fight with verdugo will be cut
the mine section will be cut the maze
section will be cut the bug nest will be
shrunk down into like
three small rooms you'll get to the
island immediately after the castle and
it'll be simplified so jack krauser will
like fight you
here instead of some kind of crazy
ancient ruins
the fight with it will be completely
removed for pacing because that set
piece is too weird
the regenerators will appear once in
just the lab and never again
and the game will end with ashley
pulling the rocket launcher out of
leon's hands
shouting die [ __ ] and killing
sadler
and then walking away with a snappy
one-liner like
who's the damn so in distress now and
then leon will be like
what a woman i don't think it'll be that
but it's not hard to imagine you're
picturing it right now in your head
and it's scaring you because it seems
very real either way what concerns me
most about this remake is that i
don't want them to make something that
is less than the original
you can improve on it for sure it's not
perfect it's got some weird quirks and
it's certainly not for everyone but
resident evil 4 is still a classic
and i'd hate to see all the fancy new
graphics gloss over the fact that it's
lost its soul
also please remit code veronica instead
that one needs it way more
[Music]
you